the history of Photoshop begins in 1987
walk like an Egyptian was top of the
charts
now as other college kids were doing keg
stands one PhD student named Thomas now
began writing a program to display
grayscale images on a monochrome screen
meanwhile his brother John noe was
working at ILM he realized that digital
painting would be the future of visual
effects and he convinced Thomas to turn
this idea into a fully fledged image
editing program
- Thomas no John no and mark hamburger
the Academy presents a scientific and
engineering award for their work on a
derby poster sir
come on up guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you to the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences for this great
honor Photoshop would not have assisted
without the vision of my brother John
who saw the potential of my hobby
project suggested many great features
and encouraged me to partner with him to
turn it into commercial product job
became photoshop's first expert user and
as many demos were critical in finding a
publisher and a market for Photoshop
John and I would not have been in a
position to do this without in the first
place if we did not have great parents
who encouraged us to pursue our hobbies
wherever they led unfortunately our
father is a longer with us but our
mother is and is able to come to this
event
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks mama
Photoshop would not be what it is today
if it were not for the large team at
Adobe who continued to update and
improvement of the many people who
worked on Photoshop over the last 30
years one person stands above the rest
Marc Hamburg Marc Marc was the first
engineer added to the Photoshop team by
Adobe and is probably responsible for
more lines of code in the current
shipping product than anyone else
including me hmm thanks Marc
Thank You Johnson many other Photoshop
team members have contributed to
Photoshop over the years far too many to
list a few of them have been able to
come down for this event
CEDA both Russell's Jackie Dole Brian
and Maria thanks to them and all the
other Photoshop team members in
particular to the members of photo shops
Camera Raw plugin team which has been my
home for the last 16 years thanks
everyone
when I had additional thanks to all my
friends at ILM that that's supported and
encouraged this this development and in
the early days - Jim Batson a Dave Fung
at Apple's advanced technology group
that you know when I went talked to them
and and said hey my brother and I are
developing this this thing and are
thinking of taking a commercial what do
you guys think who encouraged us and
gave us that the first lead so thank you
guys - my wife Jennifer who was very
supportive during all of this and as Tom
mentioned you know we grew up in a
household where mom and dad set a tone
that encouraged engineering scientific
inquiry and an artistic expression and
that that that was really important to
us and could resulted in what you see
here so thank you so much
I wanted to thank the art teachers in
school who encouraged me almost didn't
have to go to art school though I
thought better of that after about five
to ten minutes but they gave me a sense
for composition and what really matters
in making a great image and I hope that
in building Photoshop it's been able to
realize those characteristics and things
I want to thank the many users that I
worked with over the years when I was
working in Photoshop that encouraged me
stretched me said you know I got to know
their problems and try to channel them
and bring back some of that little
training that I had before I shifted
over entirely into computers instead of
art and try to figure out how to solve
problems for them and then I need to
thank all the people who worked with me
and dealt with me as workaholic and all
the people who lived with me and dealt
with me as a workaholic and yeah I'm
happy at what we've been able to deliver
and I look forward to the people who are
able to enjoy the fruits of it going
forward and I thank my family now who is
dealing with me as a workaholic so all
the Photoshop users in the
world thank you
[Music]